ladies and gentlemen we have a new
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson Trump
Ally so sayith CNN has been elected
house Speaker 3 weeks after the McCarthy
ouer okay it's big news people are
asking who is this guy and uh what's he
going to do and videos are popping up
both of him being epically based but
also mercilessly cringe some people are
arguing that he's woke some people are
arguing that he is a an Ardent Trump
Ally Who defended him during impeachment
and those things are true but then
there's like a recording of him saying
things about you know critical race
Theory type stuff and people questioning
but uh I think I think based on what
Matt Gates said recently on Steve
Bennett waram is really really great
stuff happening and this is a tremendous
Victory uh the long story short of it is
that Kevin McCarthy was secretly
sabotaging things and and removing him
from power was the right move so either
way seeing push back in any degree I
think is a step forward now we need to
see action so we'll talk about that we
got a bunch of other stories a crazy
video coming out of New York